hey it's Evan and today I wanted to talk
about two of my favorite tools that I
use to delegate some of the important
tasks in my business and compare them
because they're great for different
things so what I want to look at is
oDesk versus Fiverr and this is prompted
by one of my YouTube viewers Jim who
wrote in talking about oDesk and he said
he's been using Fiverr a couple times
and I wants to go to Odessa looks more
professional I've used both and the main
reason here is to be able to outsource a
lot of the tasks things that you're
doing in your business that you don't
have the skills you don't have the time
to do you want to focus on a higher
level bigger picture stuff for your
business you want to free up your time
this is a great way to do it and if
you're going to choose oDesk and fiber
it depends on the criteria that you're
looking for the type of task or job that
you have to show you a little bit about
my background on both this is my Odessa
profile this is a job that I posted
recently so I've been a member since
2010 I've spent over $20,000 with them I
have a perfect score these are from the
people I've hired so 47 people have left
positive feedback for me I've hired 62
people in total four different jobs so
spent I've spent a good amount of money
on here I don't know what the exact
figure is I don't know what kind of the
thresholds are here but I'm not just
spending like a dollar here I'm spending
some some money here on this site fiber
I've been on for just over a year I have
bought 84 different projects from people
and I'm also sorry I've sold 80 for my
buyer and a seller so I've sold 84 and I
bought 23 from different people so I'm
active on both sides here the things
that I find really helpful in helping
you make a decision between oDesk and
Fiverr I started on oDesk and oDesk I
find is people who are more professional
and want longer-term projects so the
first thing you want to look at is do
you know what you want or you're trying
to browse so for example if you know you
need help with your website you need a
web developer I would go to Odessa
because they have categories this one
right here website development I can
on that I can post a job here I can look
at people who have had a lot of
experience they've worked lots of hours
and I can hire them for a project I go
to fibre when I'm not quite sure what I
always need so fiber is much better if
you're just kind of browsing so I've
used it for some business stuff I use it
for some personal stuff I go to the home
page it kind of has some fun stuff
typically on here you can click on so
say I click on video and animation on
doing videos I can click the Browse to
see maybe there's something fun that I
can use for my website so maybe I could
speed color my logo maybe I could put my
logo in some kind of typography moving
tacks I come here for ideas you know
create an animated character video I
come here for ideas and I often will end
up buying one and apply it to my
business but if I know I need something
specific if I know I need a skill set
and it's going to be a project then I
usually go to oDesk the second thing I
look for is short term versus long term
okay if I need something that is short
term but finding something quick I need
a quick hit then I'll usually come to
fiber because they will get it done for
you really quickly and I'm not hiring a
person on a long term contract whereas
oDesk is much better geared towards
longer term people this is someone who
you can think of as a part-time employee
for your business so if I was hiring a
website developer you know I might go
through these I might find somebody I
like I post a job posting and maybe I
really like Alex and he applies Alex
becomes part of my team and I treat him
like an employee even if it's a
part-time you know if it's freelance
it's not you know he may not be working
for me every day but I consider him as
part of my team
we're with Fiverr it's much shorter term
you're you're offering hiring just for
one thing you can do repeat projects it
does happen a lot but I don't really
treat them like like a member of my team
I see it more as a short term versus
long term fit so again depends what do
you need for your business do you need
them to do something really short term
or do you want somebody to be a part of
your team for the long run and the last
thing I would think about is do you want
one thing in particular or do you have a
project that you need multiple skill
sets on so for example if I needed help
with my videos
okay I could come to fiber for one
specific thing right I could get my logo
speed colored and that's all this person
will do they may have other skills they
may have other gigs but that's basically
what I'm hiring them for if that's what
I need then that's great to come to
fiber for but if I want somebody to be a
video editor for me and that's what this
job is actually all about I'm posting a
position from a video editor I need them
to do a lot more than just one thing and
so then I would want to hire somebody on
a project and I would go to a desk
so this pros and cons to both I just
really look at your knee to see which
one better fits your scenario I guess so
I guess for this one here again this was
somebody who I've hired this is my video
editor and she does a lot of great work
for my website and editing my videos if
I go to Fiverr and I look at some of the
things that I've bought I'll show you
some of the details so you can look in
and see what I bought I bought a few
that are telecall joke so these are a
couple kids who they're trying to raise
money to make the girl the little girl's
house wheelchair accessible because
she's in a wheelchair and so they sell
jokes and I've used this for basically
my team just as a way to say hey thank
you for the great work that you've done
just wanted to send you this cool joke
and it's helping raise money for for
these for these two kids
I've hired this person a couple times to
clean up some audio track so I have some
audio stuff that I have on my website
this is you know this is a repeat
business so I bought from him a couple
times you can see his picture down here
over a period of a couple weeks and if I
have more audio tracks I'll keep sending
it to him but it's one specific thing
I'm hiring for him again design a logo
fix a PHP script so this is this is a
perfect example of why would hire
somebody on Fiverr instead of oDesk so I
had one particular thing in PHP that my
programmer was having a hard time
figuring out he didn't have the
knowledge set and it was very specific
and he couldn't figure it out and so I
said okay instead of you kind of beating
your head trying to figure this out I'm
going to go on Fiverr and I'm going to
posted this guy say hey can you help me
solve this problem and it was so
specific
one thing he solved it and it was great
and I see this guy as
a value I tool if I ever have another
PHP program issue that I need help with
I can always go back and hire this guy
to help me out but I already have a
programmer if I was looking for a
programmer I would go to oDesk do all
the screening and hire a programmer if
it was full-time or part-time so that's
the difference this is something really
specific one off project that maybe I
may need every now and then but if I
want somebody long-term reliable working
a project I know what I need then I
would do it on oDesk so hopefully Jim
that helps you and everybody watching
that helps you kind of make a decision
between Fiverr and oDesk I'm a big fan
of both I'm a believer in both and
anything that we can do as entrepreneurs
to free up our time and hand off the
tasks that we are not good at or don't
want to do to other people I think it's
a great resource to help us build our
business so check them out I'm not a
feeling with either company I'm just a
loyal customer and an active user if you
guys liked this video please give it a
thumbs up below let me know what you
think leave a comment if you have a
question about Fiverr or oDesk or any
other business related question let me
know in the comments I love seeing those
come in I'd be happy to answer them for
you thank you so much and I'll see you
soon